un conflit qui a fait de nombreux
blessés parmi eux des journalistes du
quotidien le monde
touché lors d'un bombardement des forces
azerbaïdjanaises sur la ville de marteau
ni d'hier le président du haut karabagh
leur a rendu visite à stepanakert ils
ont été transportés à erevan en vue de
leur rapatriement en france
il devrait atterrir en fin de journée
information qui émane du ministère
français des affaires étrangères nous
avons appris jeudi que deux journalistes
français du journal le monde ont été
blessées dans le cadre de la guerre au
karabagh quand il se trouvait dans la
ville de martigny c'est bien sûr un
sujet de préoccupation majeur non
seulement pour nous mais aussi pour les
autorités françaises au plus haut niveau
le président a kron a fait une
déclaration quand il est arrivé à
bruxelles où il a commenté non seulement
le drame avec les journalistes mais
aussi tout ce conflit nous sommes très
reconnaissants envers tous ceux qui se
sont occupés de ces deux journalistes à
stepanakert et aussi à erevan nous
sommes très contents qu'il soit arrivé à
erevan et nous sommes très contents
qu'il soit possible de les amener en
france rapidement et je crois que cela
montre la gravité de la situation au
karabagh pour nos deux journalistes mais
aussi pour le reste de la population qui
subit ces bombardements désormais
quotidiens